okay
so my name's bart badly and i'm a
freelance data consultant with a sort of
specialization
in machine learning a little bit of
background i
was in academia for a long time i did a
phd in neural network modeling
then i spent five years modeling ant
navigation
and in the last two years i've been
working
in the data science area so i'm a sort
of scientist who's turned into a data
scientist
i'm going to talk to you about data
clustering um
i'm going to start by just sort of
pointing out that
all of this ipython
information is in this ipython notebook
which can be
downloaded at github there's quite a lot
of code that i'm going to go through and
i'm not going to
actually stop on the code i'm going to
whiz through it quite quickly
but if you're interested in sort of a
better understanding of what's really
going on
have a look at the the repo
so to start off with just uh quickly
sort of summarize what i'm going to
talk about uh i'm going to start off by
just sort of
motivating why you want to cluster data
then i'm going to introduce
k-means clustering which is a an
algorithm that i'm sure
many of you have come across before
continue with some tips on how to use
k-means clustering and when it's
appropriate when it's not
then provide some insight into how you
make
decisions about which of your clustering
solutions are
good and deciding on things like the
number of clusters you should try and
find and then i'm going to finish up
with
a discussion or a description
explanation of spectral clustering which
is a
another widely used clustering algorithm
so to start off with um why would we
want to cluster data
there are two main reasons that you
you'd want to cluster data the first is
as a sort of pre-processing stage um
to another data analysis
and the second is is actually just as an
exploratory
data analysis technique in its own right
there are a large number of application
domains um
just to name a few data summarization
recommendation systems
like collaborative filtering um you can
use it for customer segmentation or for
segmenting
other sorts of objects into into
coherent groups
um document clustering it's used a lot
in biological data analysis for
clustering gene networks
and for things like analyzing social
networks and networks in general
um so it's clearly it's a it's a
key tool for a data analyst and
whilst there are many tools out there
that provide you things like
psychic learn which are fantastic
i think it's useful to actually
understand a little bit about what's
going on behind the scenes so that
if things don't work out quite how you
want them to
then you stand at least some chance of
working out why
things aren't working out it's a
slightly weird sentence
so k-means clustering uh
i guess any of you that have looked at
clustering data will have
oh no so i'm going to have to run the
code
it's all sorry um
no not that one
cell ah
run all does that just go go through the
whole thing and
okay
that's not looking nice okay
sorry about this okay
so k-means clustering um
as i said that this uh i'm sort of
using some of the code from the psychic
learn to run
k-means clustering and things but um a
lot of the code i'm i'm
sort of writing myself have a look at it
in the
in this in your own time so k-means
clustering
anyone that hasn't come across it it's
very simple algorithm
um it's very easy to understand it's
very easy to implement
and it works pretty well in a lot of
instances
so the basic idea is it's an iterative
algorithm
you start off by deciding how many
clusters you want to look for
you initialize your cluster centers
either randomly or some
other way a little bit more involved and
then you just
step through a two-step iterative
process where you
assign each data point to the nearest
cluster center
and then when you've assigned all of the
data points
you update the cluster center to be the
mean of the data points that have been
allocated to it this is a convex
optimization program
problem so it means that you will always
find a solution
however you're not guaranteed that this
is going to be the
globally best solution so i guess that's
the first
thing that you should know about
clustering algorithms is that
you don't necessarily end up at the best
solution
and so for k-means clustering the the
standard thing is to run it multiple
times
and pick out the best solution that you
come up with
i'll come on to what the best means in
the context of kb's clustering in a
minute
so just to show you uh that it works
we've
we've got this very obviously clustered
data set
and this shows the output of running
k-means clustering on
on that particular data set um what
you're seeing although it's almost
impossible to
distinguish is the the cluster center of
the
process that was used to generate the
data and the
k-means clustering center having run it
to a
point where we decided that we're happy
with the
solution um in this instance there's
just two
data points that are wrongly classified
and we know they're wrongly classified
because we've set up this artificial
data
but actually they look like they
probably belong in those uh
the clusters that they've been assigned
to anyway
so um when's it useful and when's it
not going to work so well so the first
instance that it might not work so well
is if our clusters come from data that
has different scales in different
dimensions
so here we've got a similar sort of
clustering
um problem uh to the human observer it's
obvious that there are three clusters
there
however if we run k-means clustering on
this
data set we end up with
this solution which is clearly
sub-optimal
um and that's because k-means clustering
implicitly assumes that your data
is well described by a centroid
and is of the same scale in every
dimension um so number two take home
message
make sure that you understand that your
data is scaled to a
reasonable extent it's the same scale in
in the different dimensions that you're
using
so what happens if we add in more
dimensions
um so try to visualize
visualize three dimensions so in this
instance i've just added in a third
dimension
let me just make sure i'm yeah so i've
added in a
third dimension that contains no
information so the third dimension
has the same mean and variance for all
three clusters
and we can see that the original two
dimensions that we
played around with before we've got nice
separation and obvious clusters
if we plot the first and the third
dimension we see that there's an overlap
and the
second and the third we again see that
this third dimension contains no useful
information
is this going to be a problem is it
going to disrupt our
clustering algorithm and the answer in
this
case is is to a large extent no um
so despite this this added dimension
that contains no information we're still
finding a useful cluster
we can carry on adding in more
irrelevant dimensions
and still end up with with reasonably
good performance so
uh in this case i've increased the
dimensionality to
9 or 10 dimensions and for each of these
dimensions
i've kept each of the clusters have the
same mean
and variance so just adding in
dimensions that have no information
that would help split the data into into
clusters
because i know that the two dimensions
that actually hold the useful
information
the first two i can still plot those two
dimensions and see what the clustering
results look like
so in this instance we've added in
seven new dimensions and it hasn't
really affected things
things that things are still working
okay we've got a sort of a handful of
uh data points that are on the edges
that are starting to get
um wrongly uh classified
we're still doing okay so
what happens if we have a large amount
of variance
uh in just one of the single dimensions
that we've added
um so in this this case we've gone back
to three dimensions
we've got the um original
um nicely well separated two dimensions
that we've been playing around with
and showing the other plots of the
second versus the third and the first
versus the third
and we see that this new added dimension
has uh a different scale
and just sort of going back to what we
were saying before we know that
if we have different scales in different
dimensions it can cause problems
um so in this instance when we run the
k-means clustering
it goes horribly wrong um
and we just end up with a bit of a mess
so that the
um sorry i'm just okay
um so
play the same sort of game um but we
just add noise into this
third dimension and we get the same
problem so noise is rather than having
it
uh a gaussian spread it's it's just a
random spread over the same sort of
range um and again it can disrupt the
clustering
so what does this tell us
um it tells us that we should be careful
when adding in
new dimensions to our clustering because
every new dimension that you add in if
you if you're not sure that it's
actually providing information you're
also running the risk of introducing one
of these things that will break the
algorithm
there's another point that is
worth knowing about which is in high
dimensions
you run the risk of one of the features
of the curse of dimensionality which is
that
as your dimensionality of your problem
gets larger and larger
the notion of similarity actually starts
to break down
so the difference between if you if you
measure the euclidean distance between
an arbitrary point and its nearest point
and its furthest point
that difference will get less and less
and less and less as you add more
dimensions
till the point at which um the
similarity of all
points to all other points becomes
dominated by noise and basically
uh the notion of similarity in high
dimensions actually starts to break down
um so if you run your your clustering
algorithms in very high dimensions
expect to get nonsense out um and
you will one of the things you you will
always get
a result out of a clustering algorithm
and it's down to you as a
as a practitioner to work out whether
that actually means anything
so one other thing that
i should explain about k-means
clustering before i move on to
talk about some other
aspects of of the clustering approaches
that i'm talking about
um cayman's clustering as i
said earlier makes this assumption that
your data is well described by a
centroid
and an area around it so if we've got
data that
looks like this and as human beings we
can see that
there are two obvious clusters um
k-means clustering is not going to work
well in this
instance if we run the k-means
clustering on
this particular data set what we end up
is
with is this um and clearly that's not
what we're after
so another thing to bear in mind when
you're
thinking about using k-means clustering
is have an
idea of what you think your data will
look like if if you think it's
well described by sort of point clouds
um then maybe k-means clustering will be
okay if it's if it's going to be looking
more like this
be very wary so
moving on to
trying to decide between different
results so i said at the start it's
usual to run
k-means clustering uh multiple times and
pick the best result
but i wasn't clear about what the best
result was
um so for k-means clustering
there's um actually a very nice and easy
um metric that we can use
so if we set up a an example where we
know that there's a
one clustering is is working better than
the other um so we've run k-means
clustering on
on two data sets and we've kind of
hobbled one of them giving it a
nasty starting point so that it it's
it's making some errors
um and the other one where we're doing
correctly and so it's getting a nice
result
um because we've set up this artificial
invite um
experiment we can actually plot exactly
the number of wrong and
correct labels for our clusters
so how can we automatically work out
which of these two clustering results we
should be using
um and for k-means clustering that the
final error in your clustering which
is sometimes referred to as the inertia
gives a nice
easy way to determine so if we plot the
inertia which is
basically the sum squared error between
each of the data points and its nearest
center across the whole data set
for these two runs we we see that the
first run which we know was the better
one
shows a smaller inertia score and
therefore that should be the one that
we'd pick
so moving on to choosing the number of
clusters that you look for
um you might naively think that you can
use the inertia
so look for the sum squared error
actually it turns out that that's
not the right thing to do because as you
add in more clusters
your sum squared error is going to get
lower and lower and lower
so it it doesn't provide a useful metric
for actually making decisions about how
many clusters you think should be in
your
solution so what else can you use
um there's a there's a number of
different metrics that um
all work to some extent some are better
than others
the one that i found the most useful and
the
and also in a way the easiest to
understand uh is the silhouette score
uh and the silhouette score or the
silhouette coefficient
basically measures uh the nearness of
all the points within the your own
cluster
and compares it to the distance between
the data point and all the
data points in the other clusters so
it calculates a ratio between those two
values so one of them is the compactness
of
the cluster that you're part of and
the second is your overall distance to
the
other data points that are not part of
your cluster
hopefully that'll become a little bit
clearer and maybe a little bit garbled
the way i explain that but
um if we look at the the previous um
experiment and we measure the silhouette
coefficient
we can see that the the true number of
clusters
um is three and the silhouette
coefficient
uh correctly um flags that up as being
the best
best solution so just to summarize
so far k-means clustering is
good if our data is well described by
centroids
be careful if data has different scales
in different dimensions
and try and remove any of those
dimensions if you don't believe them to
be
informative and particularly try and
remove them if you think that they're
particularly noisy and they're
likely to bring problems into
your your clustering uh
problem sorry um measuring similarity in
high dimensions
can get tricky um and some weird things
can happen that are kind of
counter-intuitive
it km's classroom won't work well for
non-isotropic data so data such as that
sort of
half moon or crescent like data
you can use the inertia or the sum
squared error to choose between
clusterings when the number of clusters
is the same and you can use the
silhouette coefficient
to choose the number of clusters that
you want to use
so what next
um i i'm a great believer in
trying to find ways to visualize your
data uh as human beings we're incredibly
good at seeing patterns
in data so any way that i can find
to eyeball my data in different ways
i think is is hugely valuable um
so this is just another way of of
looking at the same data that we
had before so the data is still this um
i think i'm working with two or three
dimensional data at this point
um and what
i am showing in this graph
or figure this is basically a plot
of a matrix so a pseudo-color plot of
the matrix
where the entries in each of the um
points of the matrix is just the sum
squared error between
the data points so we've got
a thousand data points and
basically we're measuring the sum
squared difference between
each of the data points and each of the
remaining data points
um it
doesn't really tell you much in this
instance because there's no structure in
there
but it's a starting point for a
different way to look at the data
if we look at how this data looks if we
order the
um the data according to the class
labels
that come out of our k-means clustering
algorithm
so what we've got here is uh these are
all the ones that were
classified as being in cluster one and
these are all the ones that were in
cluster two
similarly in this one these are all the
ones that were in cluster one
and these are all the ones in cluster
one cluster two cluster two
cluster three cluster three and the same
for the
four we start to see some real structure
um and what you see is a sort of block
diagonal structure
um and
above each of these um figures i've also
plotted or printed out the silhouette
coefficient so the silhouette
coefficient
is basically measuring the average of
this
block and taking a ratio
compared to the blocks that are in
different
um or being given different class labels
um and we can see it's quite obvious in
this instance
that the k equals three solution is
actually the best one
um because we've got nice dense
regions here and very little outside
the k equals four one we've got some
noise or some
poorly clustered elements here and here
and in this one again it's it's more
broken up
so this way of looking at your data also
gives you a
an intuition about the the next thing
i'm going to talk about which is
spectral clustering
so spectral clustering takes a
representation a bit like this um
it's it's a related representation of
the data
um and performs some sort of
calculations on on this
matrix or a related one but it's a nice
starting point for
understanding what what spectral
clustering is actually doing
so i'll just um
spectral clustering differs from k-means
clustering in that it looks for
connectivity between the members of a
particular cross cluster
so whereas k-means clustering was
looking for a centroid
and then looking for data points that
were near that centroid
uh spectral clustering takes a sort of
different perspective where it's looking
for
data elements that are actually close by
to other elements but not necessarily um
close by to all of the elements within
their
um their cluster so it captures well
things like that
those crescent shapes
it's also nice because it works with a
similarity
matrix
this means that you're not constrained
to work with euclidean distances you
if you can measure the similarity
between objects uh
and create a similarity matrix much like
the
um i mean this this is just a distance
matrix or the sum squared distance
but if you can create some sort of uh
similarity matrix
where the each of the elements is the
similarity between two data points
then you can employ spectral clustering
so it's
really useful for text-based data
and network data things that don't
naturally fall into a
sort of euclidean representation
uh i made that point
and also as a sort of something you
almost get for free
um it gives you a way of estimating the
number of clusters that you might
want to look for so
i'll start by just sort of giving you an
overview of
how it works and then i'll try and
unpack each of these stages
um to hopefully give some insight into
how
this or these set of algorithms work
so you start off you create a similarity
graph so a similarity graph
um if you understand how you can create
a
the distance graph sorry distance matrix
um a similarity matrix or a similarity
graph
uh is very similar you can you can take
a distance and
apply a sort of gaussian kernel to it to
turn it into a
similarity so um
points that are far away are not similar
and points that are near are
similar um
from this similarity graph you cr
construct what's known as the graph
laplacian sorry
i sort of stepped into talking about
graphs rather than matrices
i should unpack that state so
spectral clustering comes from
working graph theory and you can
represent your data in terms of
each data point being a node and then
the similarity between
two data points being an edge and you
weight that edge
by the similarity so
you end up with a fully connected graph
with each of the data points being
represented by a single node
and each of the edges representing the
similarity
you can see a few quizzical looks in the
audience but um
as i said before this notebook is
available on github and if if you're
interested
and and this is hurting your head have a
look through the the code
at a later point and and hopefully it'll
it'll be a bit more
clear so the idea is you start with this
similarity matrix or similarity graph
and from that you create what's known as
the graph laplacian
so the graph laplacian is basically
um you take the
um the adjacency matrix
sorry it's difficult to explain this
without it being complicated
and it's not it's very simple
so the similarity matrix
allows you to build the graph i'm going
to stop here i'm just i'm going to show
you
the code um you create you
construct the graph laplacian and it's
not difficult i'll show
how it's done from that you then do an
eigenvalue decomposition
and take the smallest eigenvectors
and that provides you a new space that's
much more amenable
to performing something like cayman's
clustering
so i'm going to sorry that was horribly
garbled
i'm going to try and unpack it a little
bit
so you start with a distance
matrix if we're working in the euclidean
space
we turn that into a similarity matrix by
passing it through a gaussian kernel
then we calculate the adjacency matrix
so this is going to be
a sparse version of the similarity
matrix where we
decide um we basically zero out some of
the
um values to
keep only those ones that are the
strongest links
now you can do that in a number of
different ways you can either
say keep the links that are um
within the set of the k nearest
neighbors
so you might say that the the 10 most
similar data points i will keep my
connections to and all the other ones
i'll just say that it's actually a zero
connection
and you can have that as a mutual k
nearest neighbours
so you keep the connection only if
no note i is a neighbor of one of the k
nearest neighbors of j
and no j is one of the k nearest
neighbours of i
or um
you can do it uh i can't even remember
what it's called
it's um
so the mutual and yeah the first one is
just called the k-nearest
neighbor graph um where
you keep the connection if either it's
it's one of the because it's a
sorry
you keep the connection if it if node i
is one of the neighbors of j or node j
is one of the neighbors of i
or the other instance you keep it
if only you only keep it if both
i and j are mutually neighbors of each
other
so we from the similarity matrix we
uh construct the graph laplacian um and
the
graph laplacian is formed by
um calculating the degree so the degree
is basically the sum of all of the
weights coming into a node
so that basically the nearness to
its neighbors and the adjacency
is the um similarity graph with the
diagonals
zeroed out um we take the difference of
these and that gives you the graph
laplacian
so as you can see it's a very simple
calculation that i've made sound
incredibly difficult
it's basically these two lines
you then perform an eigenvalue
decomposition on that
and if we look at the eigen the smallest
eigen values
uh that have come out out of the
eigenvalue decomposition
we can see that we have three very small
ones
and then a step and this would go out to
a thousand there
if you do the full eigenvalue
decomposition um
on a thousand data a thousand element
matrix you would get a thousand
eigenvalues we're just looking at the
smallest ones
rather than the largest ones which is
what you'd be doing if you were doing
principal components or something so
it's the
the other end of the spectrum
so from this we construct
a new set of data which is the number of
data points by the number of clusters
that we're looking for
so in this instance we're looking for
three clusters so we get a thousand by
three set of data and then we can just
perform
k-means clustering in this new
three-dimensional space
um and i'm just
plotting the similarity matrix again to
show the output
um with the class labels being
determined by the k-means clustering in
this in this
easier space to work in so
there are a number of different
applications or different approaches to
doing this
there's basically an unnormalized one
which is what i've just
described and then there's a normalized
version
in fact there's two normalized versions
and basically
the difference is in the construction of
the graph laplacian
so first normalized version is
so-called symmetric version where
up until the point at which we start
constructing the graph laplacian
everything is the same
then the difference in this instance is
that we
pre-multiply by
the minus square root or the inverse
square root
of our degree matrix um
and then post multiply by and there's
also an extra step which is that we um
have to normalize the rows of our
new representation um
prior to performing k-means clustering
in this
um nicer space for for for working in
and again this just shows that it works
um
and then the third version which is
another normalized is is just a
different way of
normalizing the graph laplacian and
in this instance it's done using a
generalized eigenvalue decomposition
as opposed to the standard one um
we we get the same sort of output
um just to show that it will work in
um the
so this is running it on the moon's data
that we had before
that we could clearly see had two
separate
groups and this is borne out by the
the zero or very close to zero eigen
values of the eigenvalue decomposition
so in this instance we'd have a good
shout at
saying that there are two clusters to
look for
and this is the similarity matrix
ordered by the output of the k-means
clustering in this
reduced two-dimensional space now
because we decided there are two
clusters
so we have just the first two
elements of the eigenvectors
and finally the output um
plotted showing that it's it's able to
find these two clusters
that are well described by similarity
connectivity
rather than the centroid
so just to wrap up
spectral clustering works by finding
connected
items there are three main approaches
one unnormalized and two normalized
just to sort of give you an insight as
to why or when you might
want to use unnormalized and normalized
unnormalized spectral clustering
effectively tries to balance the size of
the clusters
so it's trying to
it's related to a
a graph cut algorithm called ratio cut
which basically takes into account the
the size of the clusters the number of
elements in each cluster
and tries to balance that with with
splitting them into
separate groups whereas the normalized
spectral clustering tries to balance the
degree of each of the
clusters so how densely
clustered they are and it's
approximately equal to the the end cut
graph partitioning algorithm
um it works nicely for non-isotropic
data
provides a way to estimate the number of
clusters
you can use it on other sorts of
data other than just numerical or
euclidean anything that you can
come up with a measure of similarity
will be amino
aminable to spectral clustering
and it's also deterministic up until the
point that we perform k-means clustering
uh which is quite a nice thing so you
don't have to do multiple runs
well you you can do multiple runs
because the k-means clustering part of
it will give you
slightly different solutions but
if you're just trying to split the data
in two for example
you're not going to have to run it many
many times on the negative side you you
do have to create this
n by n matrix and then perform an
eigenvalue decomposition on it so it
it can get a bit tricky when you're
scaling to very large
data sets that's pretty much
everything i'm going to say so i'll
thank you for listening and